purporting to be of the golden lineage
but too weak and sickly to be truly
worthy stands the first shard-bearer
boss of eldon ring godric the grafted
ironically even the game itself mocks
him for his weakness despite his own
announcement as lord of all that is
golden the game immediately contradicts
him with his boss bar stating his name
to be godric the grafted not the golden
godrick is a boss immediately known to
the player as compensating for his lack
of power
we learn from rodericka that someone is
grafting those who approach stormvale
castle
everyone's
been grafted grafting is the process of
joining separate tissues so that they
may grow together
in godric's case he grafts the limbs of
challengers to his body that he may grow
from their strength as his remembrance
tells his story a feeble man sought
power through the grotesque act of
grafting
one day we'll return together to our
home bathed in rays of gold
godric yearned for the glory of a bygone
age hoping to return to it in a splendor
of golden light we can learn much about
his golden yearning when we consider his
lineage gideon off near summarizes so
godric the grafted lord of stormvale
despite being the blood of god free
first elder lord
he's a grotesque old fool grasping for
power
his castle lies upon the cliff to limb
graves northwest but i suspect you know
that well enough already
godric seeks the golden glory known to
his blood known to the first elden lord
godfrey
but enya in discussing the demigods
explains how godric is incapable of
achieving this
but remember one thing
the demigods are each and all the direct
offspring
of queen america
godric the grafted was but a distant
relation
the runt of the litter
his divine blood
solely diluted
despite being of divine blood godric is
a distant relation with faded power
and as such he is weak
he seeks to claim connection with
godfrey emblazoning his acts with the
figure of a beast representing the
strength of the first elden lord but he
is ridiculed by many of the residents of
the lands between
obviously the attempted connection does
not shine through
and considering his history it's no
surprise we hear much of his pitiable
story from sir kenneth height who
ridicules as much as relays the feats of
godric honestly godric's nothing more
than a jumped up country bumpkin
lord
don't make me laugh
first he hid himself amongst the women
folk to flee the capital then hid from
radon in that castle
then he insulted melania lost to her in
battle only to lick her boots rather
than die like a man
has he no shame the big girl's blouse
and to think
he's the blood of godfrey
last of the golden lineage
though you almost wouldn't know it to
look at him
yeah i almost feel sorry for the chap
the more i think of it and kenneth isn't
making this stuff up we get confirmation
of at least some of what he says in a
swords monument in limgrave it reads
godric the golden humiliated having
tasted defeat by the blade of mykola now
on his knees begging for mercy
so it seems like kenneth is speaking
reliably which would mean godric was
humiliated by both melania the blade of
mikola and radon in addition to hisari's
state of hiding amongst the women when
he fled lindell he might have even used
magic to make himself appear as a woman
to really sell the ruse after all the
mimik's veil item description reads when
godric was hounded from lindell the
royal capital this was one of a
multitude of treasures he took with him
this item lets players use fp to mimic
nearby objects so godric could have used
it to mimic the fleeing women to really
make sure he was not spotted along with
stealing plenty of other items
ever the coward
but there's something else important
about that sword's monument inscription
it refers to godric as godric the golden
the same epithet as is used for godfrey
this is another testament to his golden
lineage regardless of how diluted it may
be maybe the golden is godric's proper
or original title and what he was called
before he began his grafting
we do hear morget call him godric the
golden
godrick the golden
if the grafted was a title of derision
that people began calling godric later
then it makes sense that morget would
speak of him with his original formal
title
so godric was originally a golden but
nonetheless he was weak falling and
failing many times being humiliated by
other demigods godric needed more power
to assert his place as one of the golden
lineage and he found an avenue to such
power through grafting
but godric believe it or not was likely
not the first in the lands between or
even in his family to practice the art
of grafting to grow in power in the
altas plateau before the capital we can
find an ever jail named the golden
lineage evergell in it is godfrey the
grafted another of the golden lineage
who like godric must have felt too weak
for his illustrious line
god freud drops the godfrey icon a
legendary talisman depicting the elden
lord godfrey the description speaks of
how the ferocious warrior took the beast
regent sirosh upon his back to suppress
his ceaseless lust for battle
unlike godric and godfrey who feel weak
and need to increase their strength
godfrey the one they idolize was such a
warrior that he had to suppress his
fighting urges once again the difference
between godric and his lineage is shown
to be painfully vast
we learn that godfrey was put in the
evergell by ancient dragon knight
kristoff the night's ashes tell us that
after the first defense of lindell
kristoff earned the hero's honor of
urgery burial for the feat of capturing
god freud to graft it
the first defense of landel is a vague
event with our only description of it
being found on another sword monument in
the altus plateau which reads the first
defense of lindell a sovereign alliance
rots from within traces yet remain a
bloody conspiracy while the rot may seem
evocative of melania it could just be a
choice of translation
it can be translated without the word
rot and it may just mean that the
alliance was broken from within though
the blood reference is a direct
translation so moog lord of blood may
have been involved in this attack on
landel though from which side is hard to
tell
considering godfrey was captured after
the fight it's likely this grafted one
was on the attacking side and we don't
really have a clear timeline at all so
this next conjecture could be completely
off base but if this attack happened at
the same time that godric escaped the
capital then perhaps he saw his kin
member fighting with the demigods
through the power of grafting this could
have been godric's inspiration to take
to grafting to grow in power to gain
respect and to be worthy of his name
so godric began grafting himself his
followers and even his war hawks the
warhawk ashes read spirit of a stormvale
warhawk the talons of which have been
sliced off so that razor fine swords
could be grafted in their place
with its lord vanquished and its wings
wounded the hawk perished as it solemnly
gazed at its former home the storm is a
warhawks cradle godrick took control of
stormville castle but he did not bring
the power of the ancient storm he stands
as the first major obstacle for the
tarnished picking off the weak ones and
grafting them for his own power even
taking the power of a dragon did him no
good though he could only take the head
of a dragon small and long dead
and in this futile act we can see for
one last time godric yearned to mirror
his blood
for long ago godfrey the first elden
lord fought in the war with the dragons
facing the stormlord alone
and war was not all his son godwin
befriended the dragons becoming
companion to fortisacks whose death
lightning incantation features godwin's
golden lightning
in his final moments godric once again
juxtaposed his weakness to his
ancestor's strength presenting a feeble
rendition of his family's theme of
draconic connection
finally godric shouts for his ancestors
to recognize him then he dies yearning
to return to landel in golden glory
and one day
we'll return together
to our home
bathed in race of gold
but he could only find lordship in
stormville and only for a time
he could not escape his weakness and his
cowardice
thus
he fell
but there is a new lord ready and
willing to take his place with the
newest patch lady nefeli liu can find
her place as lord of stormville
recognized by the fair judging sense of
kenneth height nephili lou is of lineage
and possible daughter of horulu the
warrior side of godfrey the golden
in this stormville once again is led by
a warrior of a lord one who can summon
the storm once more
and that is the end of the lore of
godric the grafted
thank you for watching i hope you
enjoyed make sure to stick around if you
want to see more because i will be
making more lore content about eldon
ring let me know in the comments if
there's anything i missed or any kind of
interpretation that you think isn't
justified there's definitely a lot about
the first defense of lindell that i'm
not sure about and that could use a lot
more explanation and figuring out the
timeline so hope to see you in the next
video and thanks for watching